[Musique]
et pendant ce temps aurélie s'est juré
de faire découvrir le patrimoine
chartrain à ses enfants de façon ludique
et autrement
bonne chance première étape de notre
journée à chartres on a rendez vous à la
maison pique assiette avec victoria je
ne sais absolument pas à quoi m'attendre
[Musique]
avec chip
oui car victoria c'est une guide
originaire de russie en charge des
visites de la maison pique assiette une
bâtisse unique en son genre
quel mystère abrite cette maison les
enfants seront ils captivent et pour les
réponses consultées victoria
ici à chartres un jour il avait un nom
un peu bizarre qui s'appelait raymond
isidore merci oui pour sa vie il rêvait
d'être jardinier
sauf qu'il a été envoyé pour travailler
au cimetière pas très drôle comme un
endroit et un jour en balayant le chemin
et l'a trouvé un morceau d'une assiette
brisé qu'est ce qu'elle a fait avec son
morceau à votre amour votre à lui lâché
une façon non non non il était très très
gentille raymond résidents il a piqué
oui ramasser pique assiette
il les a regardés en disant c'est joli
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait après on est
dans notre ca oui il a mis dans la poche
et il a aidé à empêcher chez lui c'est
ça faire une collection pour faire une
collection bas vous savez tout et
pendant 34 ans et a fait une énorme
collection des morceaux brisés
au début c'était juste des morceaux sauf
que avant il habitait dans un petit
appartement au centre ville de chartres
décide de construire une nouvelle maison
la maison qui est juste derrière nous
on y va la maison pique assiette est
ouverte au public depuis 36 ans
reste à savoir si la génération 21e
siècle sera sensible à cette oeuvre de
céramique sans la moindre tablettes
tactiles on vient de personnes à voter
dans cette maison là
monsieur tout cas c est cette pique
assiette et combien d'enfants
3 combien de personnes on a maintenant
regarder cette piketty regardez cette
petite maison
[Musique]
seul ami de picasso oui c'est l'année
des époux
on y va